reject nation we have made it to the
final episode of the book of boba fett
if you have been joining us on this journey
thank you so much for being here use the force
to hit that like button and also big thanks to
all who have joined us on our patreon page so
far becoming super checks by checking out all the
content we got offer there full length watch long
as we sync up with the time code for book of boba
fett over at patreon.com the real rejects lastly
big thanks to the boys of prepper for helping us
edit down these highlights let's see what theories
come true last few episodes have been pretty
great so far i'm so freaking excited let's do it
the palace offers greater protection
if you want to abandon moss
espen hide in your fortress go ahead we're staying
the people who live here need our protection your
mind's got purpose this is your people now bubba
oh [ __ ] does fed have any
other resources to call upon
he used to live among a tuscan raider tribe in
the desert they no longer exist we destroyed
them ourselves does fed know that he has no idea
he thinks they were killed by nikto speed bikers
bastards i think i have an idea
how to draw boba fett out oh no
in the name of honor that was pretty cool to see
a whole scene with just people and makeup yeah
how robert rodriguez is feeling is he coming home
hello officer
got any power converters my
new republic certification seal
tucked as you were landing quite
a coincidence if you ask me
no oh so grand theft x-wing grow group the
mandalorian he's not here i don't know he's
on the job of moses he chose he's got that
chain mail on kroger whoa that's a terrible name
the way am i calling you that your baby yoda
you have here huh something's shiny toads
there is someone here to see you i thought
you said nobody could sneak up on us
oh no
i thought i smelled something i don't negotiate
with gutless murderers if that's not the quacker
calling the stiffling slimy i wouldn't be counting
on the people of freetown to be coming anytime
soon i paid marshall vancouver i will only
negotiate with the head of the pike syndicate
you mean the one that massacred your tuscan
family and blamed it on a speed-like game
let's do this negotiations are terminated
you're going soft in your old age we all do
god he's so creepy yeah i
love that cat cabbages here
that's a really good tent scene have the
pikes arrived not yet but something feels off
oh no
oh
can trust you guys
no oh no no best boys
yeah use those nuts come on for opposition
nice classic western thank you manners i like it
manners maketh women on tattooing manners make
us mods they're here it was just a matter of time
with them otherwise i don't want to go out there
okay then we'll both die in the name of honor
oh sure you want to stay this
is the way god damn right it is
if i may offer an alternative make it good i will
write out my statement and what i'm willing to pay
i shall go as your emissary i have no compunction
whatsoever genuflecting or even groveling dank
fair rick i boba fett speaking as
daimyo of the tatooine territories
formerly held by job in the hutt
do present the following offer
perhaps we should discuss
what you'd be willing to read
nothing
if you refuse these terms
arid sands of tatooine will once again
flourish with flowered fields fertilized
with the bodies of your death
damn you wrote all that boba fett
his words
oh cool hell yeah strike
oh
nice so cool
like butch cassidy at the sundance kid
now it'd be a great time for a little backup
free town
cool great shot
no damn the cop really dies i'm sorry about
the marshall gunned him down in cold blood dang
so look at the shininess of that paint
oh [ __ ] cool shot
honor among assassins
oh [ __ ] damn it
wow i like battle they're like the
santa menace battle droids have you seen
these shorts before they look familiar
nothing
connect with it can you protect the
others i can distract them first though
why watch out it's like a video game level yeah
boy
a bold move though man
earn back some cool points
oh no oh no be aware
i thought she said the f word yep
happy to see you too i didn't
know when i'd see you again
but uh we're in a bit of a bind here
right now be careful you keep your
head down you stay hidden until the fight's
over hey that's the shirt you got the shirt
ouch
come on you can dismantle that thing
oh i totally forgot about that
oh he's like a kai shoot
that's pretty awesome that's pretty awesome
oh
wow
oh no no no no no
nice work yes use the force young one
get to work grogo
hold its head up do it yeah
you defeated mecca godzilla
that's so awesome i love it so much oh
man that is so cool it was literally just
musing about wishing for star wars
just don't let a door close on him
no
i am not a threat nice head tails come on get
behind me pretty face holly's got you covered
hey what the hell's
oh wow you've earned it oh
[ __ ] get off that rancor
so no fire
dang this is my city
ah this isn't the first
time i beat you out on a job
there's no shame in it
look out for yourself anything else is weakness
oh yes yes yes
oh that's so cool used the ways of
the tuscan raiders to defeat them
conflicted i love cabbie
so he's like king kong in
this or something huh yeah
bubba gotta come talk him down hang on to
this it's gonna be okay a little stress ball
awesome you're not my dad don't
worry kid your old man's crafty
spoke too soon
oh my god no no no don't
worry can i where'd you go kid
what is he gonna do are you a little badass
the rancor whisperer
oh no buddy you are that of
the new ruler of tattooing
oh damn
cruel killed robert rodriguez i'm batman
damn it's wonder where you went really are the mvp
you should take a nice soak in the back to tank
it's being used huh we're starting
oh there they go cool shot
all right but this is the last time
hey
so much more clearer now that it's all come out
it's red steering is a little
cheesy to me because you get
now that it's very clear yeah it's
like you didn't write any more lyrics
just repeating bubba fetter much
better than glitch bitterness
it's thundercat in there oh cure him
yes more advanced
oh that was bad i think that's gonna get
that see i'm gonna get a little picture of it
i'll wind it back that's cool yeah i
was like who's that generic white guy
that's the new thing boba's just taking people in
curing them looks like nate's father on euphoria
from the side hit television series euphoria
yeah not enough dicks in this episode of
boba fett dance who so vance is going to get a mod
upgrade yeah i guess so i want to see his memory
special request by timothy oliphant yeah she was
like not stopping this was just a big ass fight
once the action started it's a big ass showdown
there were times where i was like is that john
favreau episode but there were so many shots so i
was like especially was walking through the city
oh okay like this feels very el mariachi yeah
yeah exactly you can feel that austin texas
sleeping in all this all righty well here we
are um i got mixed feelings about a lot of this
because it's one of those episodes that's like
as an episode it's fine like if there's a lot
of really exciting moments especially like when
you isolate certain scenes they're they're very
rewarding and there's some really strong emotional
payoffs in a lot of ways like there's definitely
a lot of positives uh throughout this episode
and then kind of factor in that we're telling
the the book of boba fett and the story as it
is as a whole for a season and that's where
i think a lot of my conflict with how i feel
about this finale sort of comes from because
like i said there's a lot of positives that are
truly exciting stuff you know like i i loved the
stuff with grogu you know him showing up in the
x-wing was uh i was like whoa what the hell was
why luke here yeah or at least r2 it looks like he
chose you he says i'm dropping you off immediately
so that was a nice surprise it's cool that
luke let him have the x-wing to fly back and
i think you can set the x-wing to some type
of autopilot yeah to come back yeah or or
you don't you know groggy didn't help with
that yeah so then uh you you could do that
and so that was a really nice moment like
everything with grogu honestly was just so
awesome that's it's funny because like his his
emotional beats were so strong and him reuniting
with dinjaran too in the middle of a battle
i thought was great this had so much of the
classic western vibes you know protecting a small
town and the way the showdown ultimately unfolded
was uh reflective of many westerns but doing it
with a star wars style and you know i i thought
everything with a rank or two was just awesome
to behold like it was it was like watching
like godzilla versus call you know or pacific rim
having that epic massive kaiju type of flair to it
and of course seeing bobo riding the rancor making
you think of the holidays special in a lot of ways
but realizing it here was just really awesome
and also you know like boba you have finally
rockets and rocketing around jetpacking around
which was really fun and him and mando side by
side as well uh was really great you know and
i like to i like the exchanges there's there's
things about handling cad bane that i want to get
into i like certain exchanges that happened there
um but the the the out the the end result
comes down to more than just some nostalgia
like or love i would say for cad bain it comes
down to way more than that because you gotta
you gotta kind of isolate it as it is as a season
of television and what they did and so yeah yeah i
feel like we're kind of on the same page i wish
they had thought of it that way sure yeah yeah
sure and then boba finally get like like i said
there's a lot of like great isolated moments
the post-credits thing uh it's it's cool to see
that cop anthony is alive because i was like nah
i should have wait for him to just die
and just yeah he's mentioned it you know
hey you know it's it's off-screen
you know you never know true you know
um and and even with even with the way cat bane
died uh what i like is the trajectory of the ark
and and that's where i think some of
i feel like this show would work best
if yeah if you watched only the boba fett episodes
of clone wars and then when you watch this then
it's prayer like it is maybe his episodes of
mandalorian too you throw that in there and
but that not even really you need that i feel
like you need to watch those boba fett episodes
and then you go and watch this so that way you
feel more of what they're implying with the ark
to especially with the fact that like cad main
helped train him and they did establish that
per their exchange here but like i
said if you haven't seen clone wars
you wouldn't be made privy to such a thing you
know you wouldn't know that and it's kind of
just a line that's mentioned here so when he does
take him down i like that he defeats him as the
new version of boba that he is now not through the
gunslinger fight but through using the the tuscan
raider weaponry to take him down and win and like
i think that's cool and representative of how he's
changing who he's who's embraced himself to be
uh at the same time though like with cad bane
it's it what the my feeling is is that you
introduced him in the on the last episode as this
like oh [ __ ] there's this new menacing threat
who's come to like they give him an entrance yes
you know he is this menacing threat just walking
in the desert like i'm just gonna walk my way
through this desert i'm gonna kill some people
and i'm gonna turn around as low as i want to and
relish every word yeah and then he doesn't really
do much in this episode when you think about it he
like kind of intim tries to intimidate boba then
he has this brief fight with him and then he's
just dead yeah and so it's like on two levels
like oh that's a bummer we just got cad bane
back and they totally treated the last episode
with that level of nostalgia love of cat beans
in live-action form isn't that exciting so let's
say you eliminate that now it's just okay the cad
maiden character i've never seen clone wars let's
just watch this oh they really hyped this guy up
i guess it kind of resulted in like a 30 second
fight with some monologue either and it was kind
of like the end of it you have no other context
it's kind of like the original boba fett portion
he shows up he looks really cool and then he gets
taken out pretty easily see what dawned on me and
it was kind of early on in the episode was when
mod girl the whatever her name is the i don't know
something the main mod girl was like no we can't
go back to your palace we have to stay here and
fight this is my city and boba's like this is
yeah it will stay in my city too it really hit
me in that moment that i'm not as invested in this
as i would like to be this is not something that i
think as a season they've really built up to well
because i haven't got to experience at all how
the pikes being here have affected the people we
haven't seen like man they're really they're real
yeah like oh man this place was a great delicious
amazing people yeah yeah you couldn't shove the
tyranny of the pikes maybe at all i mean like
yeah they wiped out the tuscans and they blamed
it on the biker gang but even that is like
way more specific to boba fett and removed
from everybody else on top yes like i gotta see
yeah like we got to see them like mess up like
uh wipe out the tuscan raiders sure and like
you said just very just spotlight on bobo for
that moment but in terms of like my city and
what the pikes are really capable of doing
you know i'm like well the tuscan raiders were
not the size of a city so i don't really know what
what it is their influence is doing that's so bad
and i never got to have a scene where i'm like
wow this is really affecting me i hate the place
yeah or even for cad bane other than him shooting
koban other than that one scene of like man they
really built this guy up yeah and i didn't really
get to see just how much of a of an ultimate
threat he is and it's like you know some somebody
argue like well that's why you got to watch clone
wars and sure but even with that i'm like well if
i just watch clone wars i'd be bummers i'm like we
just brought him back now he's dead yeah yeah it's
not much of a of a true payoff in that regard and
so i think as a season as a whole i didn't really
feel like i got to know who boba is and i did and
fennec was kind of like the mvp and so many things
and i felt like i didn't really really get to know
who she is either like they they have the thing
with the pikes killed the tuscans and they do the
flashbacks because it's been so long to spend time
so they do the flashbacks and then fennek ends
up off in them yeah shouldn't that be like a boba
moment shouldn't that be like boba's revenge yeah
there's a lot that should feel a lot more personal
in a lot of these transactions of violence i
think what was missing for me is while there
was a lot of excitement and while there's a lot of
entertainment that i really did enjoy don't get me
wrong i'm not just saying that to be nice like i
was a there's a lot i had a lot of fun with not so
much as strong early on in the fight scenes um but
later on i started really getting into it a lot
it's the it's uh i feel like there's a i like
weirdly a lack of soul is the way i would put it
yeah yeah yeah there's a lack of resonance
or a lack of real meat to get invested
in everyone's motivation it's like boba fett
shows up and after this experience with the
tuscans he bonds with the the place and then
for the rest of the time he's just kind of
saying you know like this is my you know these are
my people this is my town this is my planet now
but there's no really yeah we don't really
get any kind of real investment into what that
means what emotional experiences cause that what
challenges are actually at their feet in terms
of establishing some kind of order mitigating
between all the different families like we see
him talk to you we see a bunch of like political
debates but it's like you said we don't really
ever go and have any personal time with the
people of espa or the other surrounding areas
the way we do with the tuscan it feels like the
most development happened all in the flashbacks
and everything in the present is sort of like very
just straightforward no i've decided this is my
town so everyone should respect that and they're
not respecting it so i guess we have to fight
and while i well we liked episode three more than
pretty much the population of planet earth yes we
liked it more than most people i was had a lot
of faith that they were still building up to
something gratifying and really interesting
and like the let's just cut face facts or the
mandalorian [ __ ] those two episodes of mando and
the story lines derived from there had easily been
the best part of of this season and i really liked
the flashback episode like episode two and four
i thought were really great really strong stuff
um never reached quite the emotional heights of
the mandalorian episodes and so my thinking is
is okay if you're gonna do two episodes in your
series that about book like where you're building
up building up building up and then you're gonna
put that story on hold but really put the brakes
on that shift all your focus to mandalorian 2.5
then you can't just do one more episode like you
got to have a couple more episodes i feel like
the show treated it like they really built up to
this climactic finale but i'm like i i feel like
we just started learning like the bike just
showed up and now we're here yeah i feel like
there are two episodes worth of stuff happening
on tatooine that we literally just didn't watch in
order to watch the dinjara story and hey i'm not
complaining that that's there at all but it does
it does seem as though that it feels like instead
of having all the mandalorian 2.5 stuff be
complementary to the boba fett story overall it
really does feel like oddly structured in a way
where this feels like a big setup to explain why
anytime we go back to tatooine boba will be there
it's like sort of what this feels like in
this moment of like okay and mantos season
three will probably check in with him from time
to time or something and and they don't really
the way they do resolution at the end uh didn't
feel like much of a payoff and felt really corny
you know like they just they walk together there's
black croissant and there's [ __ ] uh the mod
gang and like i really felt like i didn't get to
know anybody and i did i really didn't feel like
at the end of the day that's that's kind of my
issue is i feel like i just started scratching
getting to know people and now i feel like my cup
is have very half full on my connection with all
these new people yeah you know because you get all
these interesting introductions but then yeah you
don't get any character beats with any of them
so then by the end in the big battle it's sort
of just like all these western archetypes you're
used to seeing of people who aren't willing to be
pushed around any longer and even with the like
i i like the mod gang a lot more than most people
as a part of this show as a sort of kooky detail
but that especially the the sort of lead female
mod who's doing most of the you know talking in
this episode who is sort of the most spot lit
in this episode feels sort of like a different
character from where we picked them up
the first time and i feel like all that grit
like we picked them up and they're like you know
tagging stuff and they're clearly like a gang of
some kind who's not on the up and up and it feels
like none of that carries to the end and so you
know you have this political situation you have
these desperate people but you don't really get
the circumstances of their desperation beyond
lip service and it's interesting to me because
you know it's a lot of the same creative team as
the mandalorian and yet a lot of the complaints
people had about the mandalorian you know moving
really slow and not actually doing much with that
time as much as i i like this series and i liked
probably each episode more than
the sum of all the parts together
it does feel like a lot of those complaints
people i would hear apply to the mandalorian
i would more aptly apply to this it's like you
have a lot of really cool imagery and a lot of
really cool setups but ultimately it doesn't feel
like we went very far with any of them and there's
a bunch of stuff that's introduced and then that
happens off screen that gets you know these payoff
moments in a finale like this but yeah that don't
ring past the initial in the moment experience
of watching it it's like i i i feel like robert
rodriguez has gotten a lot of crap for the series
particularly for his episodes and and i've liked
all of his episodes to some degree i had maybe
gripes about the first one but this one even i
thought was like really fun and really thrilling
uh but yeah just at the same time it
feels like they didn't actually have as
fleshed out of a plan for doing this as its own
series as it felt like they did at the start
no no not in as much of an evocative tone either
no it's like all the parts are there and i feel
like you don't have to make boba fett the same
character as dinjar and a lot of people like
why wasn't the mandalorian just boba fett
like you can have this more stoic silent
character who does just want to you know go on
the up and up and you know clean up tattooing
whatever that is but i don't know we have to
yeah feel the urgency of that motivation too
and so when he's asking him like what's your
line you know like what's your motivation for
doing this i'm still not sure yeah that's what i
mean it is like because i don't want to pay you
watch idiots deal with this yeah i'm like i don't
i feel like you're really connected to tuscan
raiders but you keep saying like this is my city
and stuff but we never really saw you connect with
with this planet we never really saw your
true connection to it and since the tuscans
are kind of sequestered away from everybody
too that almost adds an extra layer of okay
why all the other people then who aren't with the
people that you spent so much time with that had
these formative moments and you think there'd be
some payoff with him having a moment to like honor
the tuscans in some way because he finds the
truth out yeah yeah either be something there
i don't know what it like putting up something in
the city that honors the tuscany yeah yeah yeah
yeah whatever yeah some kind of tuscan monument
or something a way of honoring them because yeah
i didn't feel any like cathartic reward with
his story when it came to i kept feeling like
they're building up to something and i really felt
like i grew to love boba by the end of episode
like by the time we were like on three or four
i was like i really love this guy if it's the
flashback stories who he is in present day he's
kind of a boring character yeah because he's
present he's kind of born he's pretty boring yeah
and and it's funny because as much as i'm with him
and i like that character i too was like i feel
like you gotta make a statement to all these
other people because all you do in most of these
scenes is you walk in you tell people you're lying
you know like you you be neutral when the tusk's
gonna show up can you do that yeah okay cool and
that's that's it like there's no even debate there
he just kind of says his piece and then people
are like okay fine and then they don't follow
through on it and that's not really as intense as
you know i feel like they they bothered to
have like the major domo and the mayor and they
have all these political pieces and there's almost
no political situation dealt with at all no no
not at all it's like the pikes always show up in
these likes real isolated moments yeah and then
the main pike's just chilling in his little fan
cave you know she's always there waiting on words
yeah it really lacked uh i kept feeling like they
were building up to something out and i guess
i was more i really wanted to love this episode
especially after really like three great episodes
back to back for being like my personal favorite
and then from the boba fett from the first four
episodes and while i think there's an argument
we made that twos probably before before it was
my personal favorite i had the most connection
to and then five was fantastic and then six was
awesome and then this one i was like i really
just didn't want to let go of that love
yeah and then i just found it kind of like sort
of slipping yeah and and then like oh you're kind
of getting me back uh i never it doesn't quite
reach the heights i wanted you to hit by the end
so the action in the beginning was really off
to me like i thought i liked the scene there's
a lot of cool action don't get me wrong there's
a lot of really cool action from like a lot of
really cool moments and shots some of that robert
rodriguez cheese that i i do like like him like
yeah put them on the carts and the cart toppling
over and all that stuff like i like some of the
cheesy rod rodriguez like once upon a time in
mexico desperado types of [ __ ] fighting scenes i
think those are fun um and then getting to see how
he like all that cgi effects that he's become more
well well acquainted with you know things like
spy kids 4d uh or so it's just fighting for one
doesn't matter but uh lost souls or whatever is
that two oh yeah probably right spike his spike is
3d and then there's a four that no one really
saw yeah and then uh then there's uh you know
lead a battle angel it's like i thought he
captured the stuff with the rancor really well
like that was really exciting would i like to
have seen him bomb with the rancor a little bit
i mean granted it did work on me
because i'm gonna go help i was
but one shot did they're shot down by one of
those droids sure that so uh yeah when uh the
raincore shows up would like to see them bomb with
it so like those those fight scenes were cool but
then some of the there was just some moments i
can't really recall them right now especially
with black or scientific i was like what is this
fight scene oh yeah where they're all like oh
they're just tackling him yeah yeah that was a
bit kooky i'd be i i thought the action was i
know everybody points to in that but like even
black chrysanthemum though man like they don't
really like didn't get as much of a moment as
he could have just like he seemed like they were
building up there and then they don't you don't
get that catharsis that you that you think they're
going to where it's like the ultimate tying
the storylines together i'm like i feel like
there's a whole chapter from the book of
pope it's missing i feel like several pages
fell out and then somebody hastily crammed some
mandalorian pages in there just to pat it out
like yeah it does feel like stuff is is missing
and it's so strange to me that it should feel
that way especially when i i felt like okay we're
deviating we're doing these two star wars overall
and also mandalorian heavy episodes there has
to be a reason purpose for doing so and and from
where i'm sitting it really doesn't feel like
it and i don't know i'm i'm very taken aback by
that oddly like i think i think this story feels
more necessary to watch the dinjar and stuff and
i'm like i don't really feel like it's that unless
you want to get some facts about how boba's alive
you know you don't it doesn't really feel it
and i where i feel especially let down is fennec
shan more than anything else she gets nothing
additional she's not she's not a person really
she's this she's really like the one who seems
to she's just cool she seems to call the shots
yeah more often she seems like she does most of
the business she's the straightforward pragmatic
one who knows how this [ __ ] works and she's not
but she's not much of a and as as badass as she is
makes me kind of question what happened with
her in chapter five of season one gunslinger
i'm like damn how did your ass get taken down
because i see you just show up and like everyone's
like oh my god they're shooting us from everywhere
yeah she's everywhere yeah she shows up she breaks
through the pike tent ninja batman's her way
in there i've completely forgotten about her
by that point too yeah she's not she's not really
a character and uh and their relationship her boba
doesn't really grow beyond the surface of both
of those characters they're like stoic avatars
by the end they're like avid like game characters
you select just to have some cool that's to do the
fighting but you don't really feel like yeah
there's a lack of an emotional payoff respect
like like you were talking about the campaign
scene that was like some of the most emotion
boba showed yeah um yeah still but but that moment
is undercut when you're like oh he's dead now he
we're going to kill him now so this is the problem
with the episode is like most of its action
yeah which should feel like super rewarding
and it's exciting and entertaining but when
you're breaking down the story it feels a little
lackluster well that's the thing is for me just
looking back on this here and now i feel like the
the writing to me is what has let this season down
the most i mean again i know of all the
directors robert rodriguez gets the most sort of
uh [ __ ] for some of the choices he's made this
episode especially i thought from beginning to
end i was pretty much pulled in there maybe one or
two fight scenes that felt a little wonky but for
the most part i thought it was really punchy
really beautiful designs as always but yeah
just like here and now with everything it feels
like the writing of this season was really like
undercooked or something it just doesn't
feel like the same group of people wrote
this as wrote the mandalorian and yet they did
you know nah yeah i felt like they just made
it really fast yeah it feels like they they
wrote it really fast and they didn't either
you know finally put a lot of tlc
into those mandalorian episodes
they did and i i'm so i guess that in the long
term i'm sure that's what's most important because
unless there's a second season of boba's but
they don't get you anything to be excited about
for the future well no and the thing is by the
end you want or i was hoping that you know all
these ragtag players we have a mass between
boba and fennec and chris santan and you know
their little consortium the mods you want to feel
like there's some kind of fully realized team and
and maybe even have some kind of yeah cathartic
moment where it's like uh yeah we prevailed and
and i don't begrudge at the the flip side of that
where it's like we barely made it through this
uh but at the same time yeah they just feel kind
of like a a bunch of people who could easily split
up now that this is done and uh you know i don't
know i wanted to feel like there was a greater
sense of purpose and i don't mind things that are
anecdotal or or you know slice of life even not
that's really a good adjective for any of this
but but it doesn't yeah feel it feels like
they directed this to be something deeper
than it actually is oh well i feel like
maybe if this was a cartoon i would have less
to complain about or something but yeah maybe
but then again i don't know like the the various
anime shows are beloved for some of their
episodes man um the [ __ ] last season of clone
wars is some of the most intense [ __ ] i've
ever seen from star wars i'm like on the like
that last year i'm like on the edge of my seat
uh yeah that is um yeah well i'm a little i'm
kind of pretty disappointed in a lot of ways
but then this the show of weirdly this this
show also gave me some of the most memorable
star wars moments ever and uh like episode five
it's just so funny how both of them couldn't
complete their training as fandom and gregory
because they were so distracted by their longing
together yes but uh yeah other than like the ninja
art stuff is perfect i'm [ __ ] hella excited for
mandalorian season three but if you were to
announce book of boba fett season two i'd be like
uh i got a different uh different main director
to helm please or get some just take some variety
maybe draft these scripts uh all with one
idea in mind why do we have a pen that make
to make this [ __ ] go longer yeah it's weird i
i almost felt like you should have more time to
hammer that stuff out and coordinate it all and
yet it felt like somehow all these were written
like like they all got a brief on what the general
idea of the season was and then all of a sudden
they were written in a vacuum separately from each
other so they all feel like they kind of match but
not in any like really synergistic way
i don't know go yell at kathleen kennedy
yeah i ruined star wars somehow they'll say this
is like woke mobbed crap and i'm like all right
yeah man there's two women when they
went on the roof to fight girls get
it done the whole episode was about that
too woke guys what'd you think about this
and uh we will catch you guys soon thank you for
being here on this journey with us regardless um
i it's so strange because like yeah i liked
i liked all the episodes the other one that i
felt was a little bit empty to me was episode one
and i was like i'm willing to just wait and then
sometimes it's fine you're
like that's weird that was
one of the most exciting i was like
the most that was a really like it
aimed to be exciting action-packed finale and
yet i somehow felt disappointed as a story so
you gotta have those character motivations locked
down all right guys we'll talk with you soon